pick up Griffin Griff Griff ready all
right I'm ready yep yep it's over here
l1 l1 I [ __ ] up guys I fell off that's
a boy
just wife my witch in the brain but it's
not showing on my screen that I'm on
dogs horses less yeah I don't like any
other [ __ ] I'll switch it from this yeah
if you press select it tells you
we should I go with I would say it left
it's definitely easier it doesn't matter
right so that's on the other side wait
who's over here who's over here that's
that's so hype and milord on that side
so I'm with them yeah yes okay so what
you're gonna do is I don't go three two
one plate you're gonna jump here and
I'll go to high first
go ahead you good
it almost broke it off of it to me am I
gonna get it if your honor no I think
hype was on it
you melted I need some ammo we should
have probably would I have literally
nothing
go ahead unreal alright man little drop
all right Griffin [ __ ] yeah you had to
[ __ ] I gotta get this ammo right here
right in my hands
we need someone to throw a grenade in
the middle
this couple adds up there all right
yep
very girl
oh good hard to go okay daddy good are
we going middle
no not yeah no yeah no we're not okay
alright now we're going minute yep go
who's on that clear I'll be on it's
alright when we shoot why right I got it
oh you have no protections dude so get
off the middle all right
just clear ads
I I gotta get off
are we coming to the middle yet no wrong
real almost Oh it'll be there yep right
now
but good legendary
[Music]
when do a cool one
nice job good [ __ ] boys we did it okay
I'm gonna do the thing in three yeah it
really does man I [ __ ] like it
wait what Obama meet these lines give me
one sec yeah and then it reloads after
you kill something too though that's the
yeah you know that's the great perk all
right so I'm best doing unless they're
doing the thing doing the challenge the
challenge what's the challenge challenge
is we got to complete it with 12 damage
and two people the people that are
holding the prison's have to change
every time okay no everyone just just no
thank you
I'm gonna get l3 okay dawg all right
and I'll do the prism I'll be our three
since I'm holding the right prism
yeah okay well it might be treats and
mellorak your are won't era l1 I'm sorry
all right cool easy here baby all right
let's take four good okay
oh yeah oh yeah oh that would be insane
bro you would not do it all right I'm
ready I'm used to my [ __ ] my other
jump my oh don't give me that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
finished the last guy so my light level
was way high mm-hmm before you pick up
let's let him get into position I
already I already picked it up bro yeah
[ __ ] it I'm in position [ __ ] r1
yeah whichever or if you pick up now
just grab the same orb wait hold up
unreal hold up someone doesn't have one
good all right what's this wait l2
should be open then - yes l2 should be
open right over there oh yeah
yeah too early way oh [ __ ] I'm idiot
okay wait till we all get there Grif
you're blowing your load kill your guy
Griffin the trip you got you gotta kill
his dad there you go good all the ways
everyone here well you guys are good you
guys are good straight back inside we'll
wait for the next cloth
I think it's entry hold on we're in the
wrong trees trees rather yeah trees in
rock no it's not it's a it's a it's an
art - I see yeah that sucks [ __ ]
words I heard Griffin where's yours he's
yours
Oh yours his trees I hear it I don't see
it
should I go I don't see it on l1 that is
good artists a rock the dogs out of the
way this one over here is out of the way
- he's right there movie he's looking
the other way he's looking away this
one's coming he's about to turn he's
about the [ __ ] turn oh there's a fish
down here is coming cool they're really
unreal
well that was oh yeah all right do
damage just do damage guys go to your
dog
we're supposed to be killing the dogs
right now this the melvoin's do damage
its do damage I get to my [ __ ] dog
alright head back guys head back
we'll jump over do something that's good
I'm actually really happy about that
it's it's not our one either so it's
treason rattle - oh it's our - no no
it's our - wait
it's our - again [ __ ] me dude I hate our
- what's yours
it's L - L - L - okay
are we clear what oh [ __ ] I don't even
see I don't see it
all right let's just go [ __ ] it if you
don't see it we're clear hit it straight
back in click click click call alright
do damage
Oh what just happened they got caught
it's too damaged
don't kill all right all right well you
see we have to do with just 12 boys that
means just one all right head back now
we're good 30 seconds
all right we got to complete it right
now guys [ __ ] I can't get up there
you're filthy [ __ ] war like it's not
our one either
no come out coming I'm heading into Rock
mines into rock mines in Rock it's in
Rock it's in Rock perfect well at least
get 12 here guys
that's a good sign all right we're yeah
Griffin way I gotta kill this guy okay a
deal was our one Oh L 3 SL 3 yeah 3 but
the dogs right there fall back fall back
dogs right here yep all right let's just
wait for this guy they're gonna grow
restless very shortly wait wait you spot
- turn around
you turned around he's turned around go
go l-3 stand my ass
Oh R 3 R 3 R 3 straight straight back
into trees
left left left right here quick click
don't kill we got a kill yeah we got a
kill let me know who needs help mine's
dead
mine's dead I need help on L 3 L 3 is
down who else I'm real yours down now we
should win no oh this is weird
what the [ __ ] you won't hit R 1 1 Melora
is L 1 and this other everyone
yeah head left let's just stay together
and everyone gets heavy
see what I mean I'm full I'm not gonna
have my although for this damn Nova it's
so good for this dude alright hi do you
know where you're going this time dude I
saw you pop your [ __ ] old I'm mine I
was like ah this is trouble he shouldn't
be here
alright man it happens yeah that's what
these that wasn't my fault that's the
depth of victory they're good for one
[Laughter]
time every other time it wasn't my fault
Oh give me one sec are you showing up on
my screen
yeah I seen arrow and killing comments
and then it just stopped
oh there we go people keep asking me for
a stream schedule I don't have a stream
schedule wait don't you let me wait let
me grab this and get in place this first
jump always ready all right let's do it
you already owe me money I owe you here
oh yeah we're good
hype you're here were you born ready l1
l1 u l1 [ __ ] r2 we can go straight to l1
and then wait a lot in real poppy yeah
go go quick quick quick
this dog is behind me that dog is moves
to the right whoa hold on we're just
gonna go behind the tree Oh me you know
I'm talking about all right
yep yep we'll wait wait my dudes what's
that what what did you do
here well go to your dog always are we
supposed to attack our dogs right now
some damage yeah and I mean you can't do
much it's seven messages go bragh yeah
yeah that's why it
I don't even waste my [ __ ] I want you
were [ __ ] moving like [ __ ] little
moves - L - OH - should be clear now
it's your fault you can't jump over oh I
didn't know that
see you gotta tell me that's not my
fault that's not my fault I was not even
you said you're used to do it yeah but I
didn't know you couldn't get side
I didn't let her up if I be getting
lured you have to stop you
I just stopped it here wasn't showing up
on my screen
mine's still going
I mean I'm fooling I really yeah I'm
full as well and I got my soup so what
kind of soup Campbell's Chunky or tomato
basil tomato peas that's what I'm
talking about
let me grab it and get in position I
want some put soul in this you can't
jump over it along with some facility
man right through the kamaal kamaal is
muscle is not that bad I like it every
we got that one
l1 l1 yeah don't boys everybody hold up
hold up hold up the dogs you guys going
way too fast
go go quick are to be the dog
okay got it didn't jump over yeah do not
jump over the dog
you look a [ __ ] white uh I look like
a [ __ ] mouth she like scurrying
slowly you stop you go something go slow
push slow push it up push follow me
jump over this into this corner
I crash I feel safer I'm in the
wilderness wait every good now what hit
it
Bobbitt all right kill your guy we're
going back here back here guys back here
over here yep
let us know what's next
hopefully it's our three I can't see oh
[ __ ] there's a guy over here nope r101
okay slow push this way all right we're
clear let's go push back here yep around
back in the rocks back to the starting
spot they'll 3sat l3 okay hold up wait
reddit right around the school there's a
dog coming towards l3 I'm gonna kill you
in real update we're on right side
Griffin we'll let you know we're coming
there okay I'm just letting you know
about this dog before he comes
all right the dog just wait wait he's
right in front of it they're growing
restless so we're gonna get this one l3
is open dogs hold on so push so push all
right go hit it head to your dogs
challenge field
head to your dogs
all right and do damage we could
probably kill but your r1 remember that
they're sure
you killed it
all right head in head in bet back
I'm not gonna make it who's gonna need
help my dog is like I think mine died
almost so we should all be good here we
can get 12 or 24 and we can kill get
ready for your spores guys grab that
[ __ ] damn it I'm gonna head to right
Patrice there's no art to I think it's
wrong
yep it's rock it's rock ok let's hit
rock all right here
it's l-3 yeah I just I'm trying not to
jump over this dog that straight into
trees
ok the dogs coming and then we wait wait
wait kill guys yeah they grow restless
already someone did kill he's walking
towards the thing right now
alright hold up
pull back pull back wait wait wait wait
wait slow push right you still caught up
with you're walking towards it slow push
pace about to turn around I'll tell you
when you can just run towards it yeah I
see it oh [ __ ] up we grew Restless kill
I need help at our three
I'm coming r3 I mean l3 I don't need to
kill Peter I'm coming out three he's
dead who still needs help
r1 everyone are one quick all right yes
[ __ ] tokens just what I wanted oh I
got something a cloak I got nothing what
kind of [ __ ] is that the amount of
work I'm puttin on this part I come to
ghost okay what are we doing yep let's
wait for everyone
oh okay oh wow
we got the irrigation key to this yeah
this is the key so we can lock oh [ __ ]
I'll show you I got you right
it's whichever one doesn't have the
symbol come on you guys well that's her
what's her calluses and why that's pulse
it's over here oh yeah we all just got
it I just follow goes actually farm at
the end yep is that the chest I keep
falling exotic boy okay pushing me
somebody's pushing me oh man I'm only
get the exotic let's go yep come this
way it's all it's all just shot down
it's down to Romans head whereas Mahna
Mahna dig down to the right down to the
right yeah and then we're all going to
axe I hate that that's the [ __ ] bikes
bye bye still alive get rid we go
you head back up and then to the left
right where it goes this oh I fell say
now you know how to utilize I'm so I
looked um geez
straight up gee and I thought no yeah
yeah I had to restart here okay here we
go alright I might go under right wait
wait we're son wait where do I go
you got a head left guys head to the
axes you see the axe symbol I don't I
don't see me do I keep going like this
way no no no Griffin come back now
you're here you're here well I see you
oh [ __ ] why I'm stuck oh my god this is
a nightmare
I'm literally stuck I stuck I can't move
oh my god I can't believe I'm stuck
right here oh it's fun this back in
Pleasure Gardens man well I think I'm
stuck see you're stuck now see I thought
oh my god this is the struggle is real I
can't believe this
oh I fell yeah there you go as soon as
you spawn Griffin crowds home looks
weird his character
yeah that's good right now where do I go
this way oh yes follow this there's only
one way to go nightmare yeah no we just
got you're a cheeky so and we if I case
so we're good
if I get to - listo from doing this oh
my god no shootin axes you want to be
top or bottom bottom [ __ ] Griffin
you're shooting top or bottom I'm
shooting top okay he'd be just a big fat
bottle milord got backs I've seen baby
our bottom 69 it's my new gamertag yep
the adventures even lock the gun yeah
buddy the hankins doh
no [ __ ] power mo drop right there
they drop right now from this guy I'm
ready whenever you guys are all right -
ready grab it all
okay so dog bottom don't forget your
thing don't forget to melee your things
Oh son top son top Oh baby
that's top Mallorca yeah I know what I'm
doing
milord Sion now the Lord I was rid of up
dibs I will go cuz I was wondering why
it was right out of my I don't know what
happened what had happened was he said
meadow I thought he's the bottom one of
you said he said top one of you said he
said bottom I'm just telling you my job
no I
yeah oh great it's me I just Griffin
[ __ ] great no it's not man [ __ ] it I
am bending over on the power bottom you
guys can wipe real quick oh okay see
what happens
oh yo you got to remember back to front
it's got a bidet yeah yeah velinkar
tushy
I got toilet paper like my booty I like
my booty lemony fresh at all times
what's going on right now
they didn't fix this what do you think
this is why does it do this
oh there we go
it's for the worst fire TV hey listen
I'm not the worst right now I'm not the
one [ __ ] up worst fire teams
representing Oh is let's see if it works
don't get some of this rift
where is it where is it oh it's gone
next looking to me you lied to me I
didn't lie to you your ass just wasn't
around area is on the left
wait dude he's like he's like stand it
on air hissing did you see that miss
candy dogs dog stop
[Music]
yeah
son middle milori you shot the wrong way
oh I did
Charlie's bottom
Travis bottom you guys that are wrong
again
Algy Melora shot mine Lord I'm so drunk
now we're not gonna spawn in again [ __ ]
like baby milord everybody
hey there's I got the most kills don't
mean [ __ ] when you don't know your left
and rights ABC I grew up in a broken
home and I don't know what you want
yep what do I do
- [ __ ] have to back out alright come on
guys are [ __ ] Melora
he says bottom where are you shooting
top or middle you're always on the
bottom so
these guys the up
i scale one to ten he's in 11 right now
yeah don't look at her jeez I oh I need
sup Oh
hold on don't grab those things yet yeah
I got him I got him I got him mom here
all right
oh hi Freddy grab it quick oh I don't
hear height
alright so middle Oh me dogs middle dogs
middle son middle
yes Charlie's bottom axes bottom okay
we're good
just kill your [ __ ] one down three to go
come on baby do that
yeah height before you grab just make
sure homies ready yeah I was ready yeah
I was down
yeah I got overwhelmed there I'm good
now I got this under control now but
sure buddy you heard about that last one
I was wah oh that is what they all say
oh my god oh I almost died there
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh I can't I gotta my god
okay
oh my living went down its tell me one
someone I'm ready are you ready yeah
let's go that's right guys over on this
other side Adam dog middle
[Music]
son middle
oh yeah Telus middle
[Music]
axes bottom
shop guys one more he's really outside
yeah all right one more fellas how was
that movie by the way I love Chris Nolan
I gotta see that I don't know man all
his movies kind of had the same kind of
thing that inception feel to it given
you too many whole too many horns on the
music line [ __ ] too many more yeah
like every wish every movie he does it
has that in it like hey I got I got or
we got it come on guys boo chat here
dog stop
son top [ __ ] almost [ __ ] that up
[Laughter]
chao-li's top I mean axis middle access
are you alright guys when we're running
the two runners you are not grabbing
first everyone else is grabbing orb and
then we're just running straight pass
yeah I'll go to the middle right now
don't forget yeah everyone to the middle
up when we're running after the second
wave this is the perfect drops floor
drops just don't fall in that and we
beat it okay daddy
okay all right
which one should I get
I'm grabbin top rate okay top middle
yeah I'm skipping - are you chuck the
one I was but now I'm skipping I'm
getting time don't stop more is dropping
guys
Laura's dropping right now oh [ __ ] the
floor drop I'm not gonna make it oh [ __ ]
it's fine we were we're ready good if he
dies it's fine love I always impress
goddammit I don't like to have verbage
oh it's fine everyone else make it and
we're good rest well history we're good
repeat it nice job guys but you mean I
got [ __ ] those privates is awesome
dude I'm gonna love that thing put it on
oh yeah dude legs drop dead 321 okay
let's get it is there a secret place to
go this on this one - yep yeah yeah drop
down come inside yep
that's what she said this one I don't
know I don't know the levers here I'm
ready I'm gonna hit every single one of
you
those are those guys are incinerators so
when they have those [ __ ] things in
the back they blow up yeah
about 22 kills wasn't enough you you
killed them too slow I gotta carry this
team I gotta carry this team what did
you tie back again
check 135 minutes I've been streaming
guys Sal has been in you know I'm not in
here that's just from early in the like
beginning you had the beginning of the
rate oh my bad on in here all right
who's got a hold I do I do I don't I do
all right good go now [ __ ] I just got
rock
oh [ __ ] that's an incinerator definitely
shoot that [ __ ]
not so much heavy is the one guys we got
it let's go finish this Sun Ellis
why am i gay axis
I got it
oh [ __ ] you tell sky for galaxy win the
job you know yep
son Ellis Ellis for photos
what's up good day thank you I move all
the way back height yep perfect come all
the others you go Little Rock okay well
bye uh me god damn it
just [ __ ]
see here he got me [ __ ] I said I'm
sitting on the shield shooter okay don't
shoot another rocket I'm not shoot
another rocket whenever you guys need to
come over here guys come to this side
don't get on it yet getting on it
alright everyone here three levels you
won
Oh
Oh
you should his chest
we jumped off wait don't don't we see
boots off now what are we doing
head to the top Griffin okay I have I
have my alt and I have my rigging top
we're over here where we were up top
that as soon as you get up there go okay
perfect
don't waste your bullets guys do not
waste bullets you're gonna need them all
right right below Griffin drop your old
nice job guys
perfect one more smooth run come on we
got it
oh [ __ ] I forgot where I was oh my god
this is like stressful god axis Ellis
chalice
X's axis watch all night let's get out
[Music]
axis telephone quick got it I got it all
right get him up it's fine I can get him
shoot his height shoot right tight
oh my god I got him fine it's taken care
of me
team effort well you guys shouldn't have
done what does that sound guys can you
stop fighting you stop fighting what we
almost have this done come on chat guys
we got this one we go now we got one
shitty phase just getting [ __ ] done as
possible
I stopped shooting stop shooting I did
yeah
I have no idea what the whole Oh guys
it's fine already little green to
remember his chest yep she's chest
Oh
it's possibly coming down cuz we don't
do that much it's closed and so off
and that's special
off
[ __ ] that Grif since we get the thing
shooting at them I Griffin head on out
all right one more face guys we got it
come on
no one could die though we have no
[ __ ] residents they don't matter your
bills sorry Sean sighs I have my salt
I have my alt - okay
you see that so it's me
come on guys you got it
stay alive guys it's the name of this
game right here chalice
Challis
all I've done axis Ellis Ellis
Tallis
X's got it
excuse me guys
thank you
she got dropped rip up the rift where
where if you needed it and they were
it's fine yeah dude I'm dying help me
over here yep yep drop the ribs Griffin
scram I'm perfect [ __ ] up shoot him
shoot him shoot him we need to shoot him
everybody should
sure them we're not dying that we there
we go
oh these [ __ ] ants yep
punch up the doorway
oh no good
unreal grab that all right let's get up
top guys we got it got to do it no one
died three two one
shut up here you guys sleep on the bank
off get off get off get up
come on boys we got it
off
go down you piece of [ __ ]
ah
off
[ __ ] them up Oh Oh all right please do
it where where yes
nice job guys I had nothing so quick I
just kept shooting him because he was so
close I felt [ __ ] [ __ ] man cuz like I
mean we were there the whole night is
glitchy man it's so [ __ ] up sin to the
past
[ __ ] off 335 sins in the past I got the
hang got the sniper we've got the hand
cannon [ __ ] off I didn't fun anymore
oh yeah one of us ah 3:30 my dude
at least it's Maxton yeah I got 335 sins
I'm actually I'm kind of happy about
that
all right fireteam leader is unrealistic
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]